this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house all right you bad [__]
what's happening it's Monday the 24th of
October
the joint is brought to you by steps.com
listen if you haven't started prepping
for the chaos of holiday mailing and
shipping you already fell behind the
[__] bike stamps.com is everything
you need to make your life easier it's
virtual 24 7 post office no lines no
stinky people no traffic no hassle no
covet how easy is stamps.com [__]
tremendous you get you they send you a
package you get a little scale when it's
time to mail something you weigh it you
put your [__] label on it and you put
in the post you put in the mailbox with
the little arrow up in the air it's gone
stamp.com give you access to post office
and UPS shipping Services right from
your computer save up to 30 off USPS
rates and over 86 percent off UPS all
you need is your regular computer and
printer no special supplies or equipment
be up and running in minutes my wife and
I love it guys take a chance it's the
holidays it's cheap You're Gonna Save
money and you can print your own postage
from any letter package anywhere anytime
so get ahead of the holiday chaos but
you got a big business small business or
a big family get started with stamps.com
today sign up with promo code Joey for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial free postage and a free digital
scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code Joey the joint is also
brought to you by
cbdlion.com you bad [__] CBD
line is back for the holidays let me
tell you something
I put that cream on I use it as a
moisturizer it is tremendous I've been
taking the tablets tremendous like the
ABX tablets except you don't see the
devil the gummies are still popping
the kinesiology tape is still popping
and you're sitting there with sore knees
or a sore shoulder you can't sleep your
anxiety is getting the best of you go
CBD line and read the third party lab
results and get back to me Jack CBD line
or put a hem in your skirt just go to
CBD line and before you check out
pressing code Joey or joint or church
and we're gonna hit you with 20 off and
their little uh Delta a gummies you'll
see the devil and his cousin go to
cbdline.com pressing code Joey joint or
church and get 20 off now it's time to
get the [__] party started Jack
foreign
[Music]
you bad [__] it's Monday the
24th of October the last week we're
going this is it this is the last
[__] hurdle if you didn't get your
costume yet go [__] yourself you're not
gonna [__] you're not gonna get
invited to the party it's funny I I
don't know the last time I dressed up
for Halloween was I was 19. I took a
quaalude and I passed the [__] out thank
God I'd have to go out with that stupid
suit on I've never been a big guy I
dressed up as an abortion I put a sheet
on with a [__] hanger around my head
and I took a quaalude and the Minnesota
Vikings are playing that night and me
and my buddy said we're gonna watch the
first quarter and I woke up like at two
in the morning with a [__] uh a
hanger around my head like Ben I could
have taken my [__] eye out and I
looked at the costume and I was like you
know what thank God I didn't go up the
[__] Aspen looking like a [__]
monkey
with uh a stupid [__] costume on but
people invite somebody invited me to a
country club party and they were like
you have to dress up I said listen if I
go
I'll go as like a gay zaro or [__]
Bruce Lee and Cato all you're gonna get
is the little shield from Uncle Joey if
I could find like a [__] t-shirt
maybe I'll work but I've never been a
big fan of dressing up as a kid I
dressed up but but by three in the
afternoon the costume's off remember
those costumes that were light on fire
they were like [__] asbestos they
came Batman Superman the hulky [__] but
if your mother was smoking a cigarette
next for you you're shot down in flames
[__] and it's true those things
were light I remember lighting a
firecracker with some kids in Harlem one
time and he had like some [__]
Halloween costume on in the summer I
don't know if they had money or not they
just said put the Halloween costume on
we're going to get your jeans on [__]
Wednesday and he [__] little
firecracker and you know those little
Sparks that come out when you light it
like he was bent over it caught on one
of his [__] little things I missed
him I must have been six or seven I was
a [__] idiot but
I'm not a big [__] Halloween guy
that's the point anyway thank you for
last week's uh
you know a lot of people gave me grief
about the Kanye thing but that's how I
feel I I can't [__] destroy a guy
that's half [__] and especially what
he's been through and I appreciate you
guys uh the comments especially with
Esther cool my friend I mean she's a
[__] brilliant chick that's the lead
that's the who's the comedian I'm sorry
cool lead what the [__] they both
[__] fly through the air you know
what I'm saying
ah anyway
uh she's a smart girl you know I went
over to check out her operation with my
wife and her best friend from college we
went up to Arthur Avenue and got some
great lunch with her and I've known her
for about a year and you guys know me
anybody who's [__] that smart I try
to get close to because she's got some
great [__] ideas
and now that I'm getting a little longer
in the tooth I wouldn't mind helping her
out and my friend Christine would you
know [__] CBD with the the little
thing with the little string you put in
your little monkey and it refreshes your
monkey this [__] is all a good idea but
I thought about it after she left
somebody's gonna create something for us
pretty [__] soon some for us to put
another little dick tube and just leave
it in there and it gets yeah what's up
dog it don't hurt sometimes I get a
little Q-tip when I was younger I get a
Q-tip just to make sure the [__] pipe
was clean you know what I'm saying you
know if you're gonna go Bonzo beans
stuck in there somebody's eating
garbanzos and it don't processing anyway
it's a joke guys but uh it's true years
ago a great comic had a like a long bit
about [__] going shopping and there's
nothing for men's balls nothing always a
chick her name was Kathy Sorbo out of
[__] Seattle [__] funny chick MTV
chick I haven't seen him in 30 [__]
years
but uh
it's been a good week guys I'm feeling
good I I got to go for a big time
physical tomorrow am I scared
I'm gonna go down you know because they
hit your you walk in at 8 30 they make
you change they send you a [__]
schedule and then they blast you with
some blood I got my ear pods hooked up
to the phone I got my little AC DC album
no Santana anymore I had to move on from
Santana with my iPod my iPod blew up so
and then from there you go in and they
do the [__] uh the [__] they put in
your arm you know to get fluids in there
and they and I'm not going to eat
nothing so for starters I gotta drive
for an hour on an empty [__] stomach
on a Monday morning on a Tuesday morning
at seven A.M
by the time I get there I'm going to
want to stab [__] and you can't
drink coffee
if it was a regular physical I could
drink at least a cup of coffee with no
sweetener in it just to get the party
started to avoid the [__] headache
but uh you got to do it raw so I think
I'm gonna go down and but once they put
that [__] in my [__] vein to get the
flu I forget what they call it they
always do the IV they always do it in my
knuckle and I [__] go down all the
time because they always come back we
miss the vein God damn it and that's a
nightmare for me so with nothing in my
stomach but you know what guys I gotta
do this I gotta do this for uh
I'm not feeling well something's not
right I know that I have the fungi
toenail and it's just it's just a chunk
of [__] brick a [__] fungi now
like I don't even need the [__] silly
mushroom gummies I could just [__]
inhale one I mean I'm at that point
they're giving off a funny smell and we
looked it up I talked to a doctor friend
of mine and he was saying that if the
fungus has nowhere to go it becomes like
a yeast and it affects everything in
your body like this cut like my [__]
you know who knows who knows I'm
[__] I'm pissing okay you know what
I'm saying I just got a bad cough and uh
I haven't been able to shake it but you
know what we're sleeping we're resting
I'm not out in the [__] road and I'm
at home with the family I was supposed
to go to my reunion Saturday night
I had a couple options Saturday night I
could have gone to my reunion
and then shot over to the Sony theater
and watched Michael schachner
uh but I really thought about the
reunion I'm gonna tell you what happened
guys Not only was I supposed to go to a
reunion
but I was supposed to have the
acknowledgment for the book this week
so Monday I sat down
I didn't know what an acknowledgment
really [__] was you know my wife said
just look at all your favorite books
and figure it out I called DJ and just
asked him
DJ I don't know what to do with an
acknowledgment he said listen first off
thank your family a paragraph and then
thank
due to Comedy and then do you know your
hometown and then thank
the girl that wrote the book with you
and I was like that sounds perfect four
[__] paragraphs
you know the the uh acknowledgment to my
wife was very easy you know I just wrote
the truth you know that was a [__]
nowhere guy and she took me in and here
we are today and then I I wrote about uh
comedy you know I I thanked Richard
Pryor for opening up my mind and Andrew
for getting me off my ass and Mitzi Shaw
and Paul Mooney and Joe and Ari and
Duncan you know
just my comedy buddies that you know
when you're a comedian or at any art you
have those four people and you can
Bounce It Off uh that's very important
when you're a comic that's why the open
mic
program that the phase is so important
because you build bonds and then it's
like Mike I got a gig I'm gonna get 100
bucks but if you drive I'll give you 50.
you know this is when you're poor when
you're poor and you're giving away 50
[__] bucks you're helping and it all
comes back to you later on somebody will
call you with a hundred dollar gig and
you're like see when you're a good
person at all Max but all that aside
like Josh Wolf something like Josh Wolf
I've been friends with that [__]
since forever you know I had to put him
in the book uh but the hardest and the
most
uh the thing that opened up my eyes
about my life thinking about the reunion
was when I wanted to thank the people I
thank the people from Union City you
know for uh
showing me my culture as a child it was
a big Cuban community and then I thanked
North Bergen
and that was tough because I had to open
up with like you know uh
the benders
and I took it to the runnies but in
reality like the Benders and the runnies
were my people I love them until the end
of time
I was in so many other houses growing up
and I'm learning from different people
the volanos they ask Elise is the
veneeries you know there was just so
many families and
I got sad for a couple minutes I was
like Jesus Christ these people are gone
like all these families like the
delorenzos they're gone the parents are
gone like I'll never see these people
again and I was listening to music
while I was writing it and it was going
through the whole Loop you know
Soundgarden Alice in Chains [__]
Judas Priest it just was going through
the loop and it came down to like the
Disco version I was sitting there for so
long
and a disco song came out and it was
from you know the 80s the early 80s
and it just brought me back to that
for like 10 [__] minutes it just took
me there like transported me that I got
happy I got sad I thought about the
people aren't around no more
and you know growing up guys I got to be
honest with you I'm very honest with you
whatever whether you read the book or my
earlier podcast and stuff yes
I [__] suffered as a child without a
family but I gotta tell you something
what I had most people will never
[__] know like I didn't have a family
and I got one now and it's okay but back
then
started like in
like I was you know I was struggling
my friends were keeping me alive when I
was 17 and 16. by the time I got to like
. I was never doing better but just the
involvement of the full day involvement
with them I wouldn't even think of my
mother and father till the end of the
[__] day when I laid down and I would
cry a little bit or whatever the [__]
but what I had as friends at that time
like my little crew Fernie Roger Glenn
Conte [__] you know Ray go guy
Tabasco runny you know that our crew
like that'll never happen in my life
again like and I felt a little bit of it
with Joe and Ari and Duncan and Josh and
all the other comedians you know I was
friends with Bert and Tom but these guys
were the people who introduced me to
that feeling we were buddies we lived
and died for one another think about it
guys I didn't go home to a mom at the
end of the day I didn't go home to a dad
at the end of the day or not even a
family member these were people that I
met going to school and playing
basketball and and all of a sudden I was
in their homes eating and you know
Carlos and Dede [__] their mother
give me a bigger piece of chicken and
she gave her own kids and you it was
just a beautiful [__] thing that
you kept me alive guys because I don't
know what I would have done with my
[__] life I don't know if I would
have jumped
I don't know if I would have OD'd it
always gave me a reason to get up like
that love always was like you know what
maybe I should give it another day
before I decide to put those cement
shoes on you know what I'm saying so
and I I never really thought of suicide
except maybe one time when I was done it
was it was coke and when you added Coke
to the mix to what you're feeling but it
made me realize about how we deal with
different things as as humans or
whatever because if Mike or Lee or
whatever would have seen me they're
going to go Joey's fine Joey's [__]
fine he's crazy and never he's cracking
jokes he's smoking pot he's eating
edibles
but it's not what Lee and Mike saw in
our daily interactions it's what I felt
you know even though I was okay on the
outside there was a [__] Silent Storm
going through me and a lot of you people
have gone through that where you're
involved in something you you work
something's going on that's just it eats
you alive every day inside but every day
you win you don't let it get to you it
finally got to me when I was like 25 24
and I ended up kidnapping that poor
bastard you know just the whole [__]
the whole [__] mind felt backfired it
becomes a mental health issue and I
understand that now now I look at my
behavior back then those couple of years
but that was one of the reasons I
couldn't walk into that reunion and
don't get me wrong I had dear friends
that were going to be there from The
Machinist to a villa to [__] Merlot
you know Chucky mcbreen Ralph I had so
many friends of mine that were gonna go
but what didn't let me go is that I have
a dear friend that always says you can't
go back
he's a firm believer in that you can't
go back you you can [__] go back and
I'm not talking about going to reunion
I'm talking about in your mind
putting yourself back there or putting
yourself in a predicament and I don't
mind that I live in the [__] past
from time to time because it builds my
confidence I don't know it just
whatever I'm feeling down I think about
what I went through back then even
though without listen to that I feel a
complete different thing I got a
daughter I got a wife you know yeah I
think my mom every once in a while this
week I had to send pictures additional
pictures
and I had to scan them through my iPad
and that's completely different than
when you look at a picture on the
[__] wall when I scan them in my pot
I got to see them without the glass and
without the whole thing
oh my God I was like
taken away like I had forgotten what my
mother looked like like you just see
like these little pictures and [__] like
that you're like oh my God that's
look at my mom you know so it was one of
those weeks guys and uh
I spoke to a lot of people who were gone
and but yesterday Saturday we had a
[__] softball game right so it was a
three o'clock [__] game the game
ended at five
and all the moms were like what the [__]
are we doing you know what are we gonna
do the dad's like we got a couple
parents had plans but I was like you
know what just get some beers and coming
over [__] house
buy it seven o'clock last night I
probably had 10 kids over here running
from the top to the bottom top to the
bottom you didn't see any of my cats for
hours those [__] were hitting
on the rocks and the whole thing
and I had like uh 10 parents in the
living room talking we made
cheeseburgers uh she made some flank
steak and we sat there till 10 o'clock
at night and I felt bad but at the same
time this is my new life what do you
want me to do I can't walk away from
these people but the reason it wouldn't
have felt the same anyway because even
though I had friends there nobody from
that crew in high school was gonna go I
mean one guy flipped the wagon Roger
passed away
Glenn had plans already and he said it
wasn't for him and I understood
and uh I said you know what if my core
is not going to go it wouldn't feel the
same to me I would and I started missing
my friend Darren ragle too I was like
God damn
it has been so long since I've like
coming home has made me miss him down
was my buddy that was out of his [__]
bird
but you know we were friends since like
1975 and then we grew up together and I
disappeared when I came back in 93 he
became my [__] unofficial comedy
driver he would work at the airport and
do all this thing and it doesn't matter
but I just missed him I just for the
first time in a long time I [__]
missed him and now I'm going into the
home stretch
because I don't know if you guys
remember my mom died November 8th so
now next weekend is when that whole
process of a debt started I went to a
party a Halloween party I don't even
know what I dressed up like that year I
do know when I dressed up that year and
I won't say it because uh I'll be
accused of different things but in 1979
we were just stupid [__] kids and
nobody was making a big deal about
anything
in fact I lost my sheets somewhere on
Kennedy Boulevard that night so it
didn't [__] matter
and I went to this party and it was a
[__] tremendous party in an attic it
was an attic and this party was by
invite only no young kids were gonna but
like there was not supposed to be any
sophomores there or anything but one of
the guys invited us his brother was
going he goes you come with me and to
get upstairs to the party you got to go
through a ladder and then climb up I had
a [__] hole and land so it's a big
attic and in the middle of this [__]
attic was a hole where you would go down
the stairs I can't tell you how many
people fell down that [__] hole that
night while we were doing it was it was
79 it was great [__] acid
we're talking about one of the parents
the other day we're talking about those
mushrooms I gave them a few mushroom
gummies and we were giggling they were
like you know it's always fun to go out
on these I go you know what the best
thing about any hallucinogenic is like
especially acid like when you're [__]
burning on acid me Mike and Lee take a
hit ass and we go to a bar or a party
whatever a barbecue
and sometime I'm with that we get we get
broken up into different groups okay
and this is phenomenal because we're
tripping on acid and we're not saying
much people are telling us [__] and
we're watching them like we're like yeah
yeah little do they know your hair's on
fire to me you know what I'm saying like
I'm talking to you but your eyeballs are
flipping your hair's on fire and guys
not now not the acid we did in the
church and stuff when I was growing up
that's the type of asset I would get
that I would be talking to you and your
eyes would be red and [__] and I'm like
oh I can't do this no more and you
always get caught in an ear beating
but you know what makes it the best when
you're tripping with your friends
that I'm talking to this guy yay and all
sudden I'll look over to see what Mike
and Lee is and the universe makes us all
look at each other at the same time and
guys it's the [__] Universe you just
go and often Michael look at me and Leo
look at me and we'll all look at each
other
and then we'll go right back to what
we're doing like nothing happened and
we'll keep doing that every 30 minutes
you know it was one of those nights
where
you know you have a [__] I didn't
really have a uh a curfew
but I I had to be home I had rules there
was rules I had a call and I never
forget they had a clock one of those bar
clocks on the wall and every time I
looked at it with the acid an hour would
pass
and it felt like 10 minutes like you
well [__] 11. boom midnight what the
[__] so I'm supposed to meet this girl I
was [__] crazy this is acid time this
ain't [__] uh Armenian time this
ain't nothing you help people say they
run on black time but Brazilian time
they're 15 minutes late this was acid
time but that clock does not [__]
stop
so this girl I was supposed to meet this
girl for the first time we were supposed
to hook up on the sly I knew her from
high school and her girlfriend came to
me and said she wanted to hook up with
me and her girlfriend wanted to hook up
with my buddy so we had a plan to meet
him like a [__] midnight but this
blonde shows up at like 11 30 great
friend of mine best friends of the girl
I'm supposed to meet and she goes listen
the girl that was supposed to meet you
is Hammond she's had a different party
on 74th Street and she sent me here to
tell you to walk over there and I'm like
what I'm not [__] going over there
I'm stoned to the gills here I'm [__]
seeing angels and [__] so she goes no no
no no no come on it's four blocks away
come on come on come on it's four blocks
away and I'm like [__] I got my [__]
costume half ripped I'm tripping my ass
off I'll never forget that when I got to
the bottom of the ladder there was a guy
with a his head in a bucket
like a spackle bucket he was just
[__] puking I looked at him for a
little while
it was [__] horrible I walked out to
Kennedy Boulevard and I'm walking down
Kennedy Boulevard with this girl who's
my age but she's dating a [__]
monster of a senior or he's out he's in
college this guy was a [__] monster
and as me and her are walking our
boyfriend pulls up
and he goes hey
what the [__] is going on why are you
with Coco and I'm like it ain't that
type of party I was [__] pickles you
know he gets out of the car I'm [__]
petrified I'm just walking to a party
with this girl he gets out of the car
he's like what the [__] so now he's like
get in the [__] cargo dog nothing was
happening because whatever I'll deal
with you on [__] Monday [__]
and he's yelling at the girl and he
pushes her and I you know I jump in
between them I go dog what the [__]
which is friends we're going to meet
this broad she just came to [__] get
me you're pushing her over this and he's
like well I'll deal with you in [__]
two days [__] and I'm like [__]
now I'm gonna get beat up by this
[__] Savage so I walked back upstairs
to the party it's [__] two in the
morning
I'm like what the [__] and the party's
still packed so I'm like I gotta call my
mother right so I run downstairs there's
a pay phone next to this bomb regs which
is right 50 feet from the party
I put my [__] quarter in there I call
my mom she's [__] half asleep she's
like where are you I go mom the bus stop
running
you know I got here a little too [__]
uh I was I I couldn't tell her that I go
I'm a little I'm a little tired you know
whatever she's like listen I don't care
what time you get home what time just
give me a [__] time and I'm like
three o'clock
and she goes I'll see you at three
okay so now the ass is still kicking
people's faces and melting the whole
[__] deal and I look back it's four
in the [__] morning now I'm like I
tell my buddies who I was dagger guys I
gotta go home this is 70th street we
lived on 38th Street one of the guys I
was there with lived on 44th Street or
something I'm like we're gonna have to
walk home guys with [__] tripping
with drunk we go back downstairs the
dude's still puking in the [__]
bucket and all of a sudden one of the
kids Brothers was like I'm going
downtown I'll take you down there
so he gets in the [__] car we go
[__] down there and he drops you off
my mother's house but the [__] birds
are chirping
it's like five o'clock quarter to five
maybe five thirty I have no [__] idea
it's light out and I'm like wow this is
my first all-nighter you know what I'm
saying like wow all right we're on to
something here oh [__] and I [__] hit
the key and the [__] door opened
and she just Unleashed on me just
Unleashed on me [__] use you [__]
piece of [__] you didn't call and I'm
like what the [__] mom at two I woke you
up I didn't want to wake you back up
she's like don't use that [__] excuse
you gave me your word you were gonna
call at three o'clock and I'm like holy
[__] she's [__] serious so I go you
know what my I'm not going to talk to
you about this
it was a misunderstanding all around I'm
sorry I'm going upstairs and she's like
no
no we're going to talk about this and I
just put my hand up and she [__] and
smacked me in the face dog the hardest
smack she ever [__] laid on me it
might have twisted my [__] head
because my mom knew I was getting to
that age
that if I ever snapped on her I she had
to shut it down like my mother didn't
come from the school a time out or yeah
there's a timeout oh my God it's time
for therapy my mom was like you did what
you [__] high-handed me I'll bust
your [__] head and I'm nipping this
[__] in the bud right now this is after
I had done the 18 day stretch in the
hospital her [__] tension she had
already had it she was she was in the
hospital after that she lost the bar the
Yankees weren't [__] with the Mets
weren't winning you know her world was
at the end of a [__] rope which is
was I didn't had no idea
so it was like that Saturday was like
the 30th
it was like the 30th Halloween was going
to be like a Sunday or a Monday like
this year you know
after she smacked me like I'm just going
[__] upstairs I don't need this [__]
and I went upstairs and just locked the
door and
you know I was upset I didn't understand
what she was all upset about
but the next morning
I opened my eyes and she was standing
right over me serious as a [__]
and she's like listen get up
and she goes I smelled the alcohol on
your breath last night
because you were drinking I said
something to her yeah
and she goes I could tell you hung over
now you know how I feel in the morning
you know like she was like a little
sense of humor you know but then she
goes listen about last night
here it is plain and simple
you told me you wouldn't call me at
three
you did not call me at three
the reason why I was so mad was because
one day you're gonna have a wife
and a daughter and a son and a bunch of
other [__]
and when it comes to women you have to
answer to them no matter what the [__]
you want to do
that's what being a man is
and I was like what the [__] is she
talking about I got a dick I got air on
my dick I am a [__] man but that's
not what she was saying she wasn't
talking about she was already prepping
me she was outside the box she's like
here's the deal you got to call your
wife and you got to call your mom and
you gotta whatever time you tell me
you're gonna call if you're not gonna be
home call me again at three and we're
cool I wouldn't have said a [__] word
to you you'd have called that three and
told me you come home at five not a
[__] peep
and I'll never ever ever talk
guys it was the weirdest thing you know
when you see something like
you're walking down the street and you
see a guy run into a car
and you go
that's weird but I'm listening to
[__] Nirvana on the earphones I'm
saying I really don't give a [__] what's
going on and then you get home
and you know two days later that was a
robbery and somebody got shot or
something
and you actually you know you're not a
witness you didn't see the guy's face
but you saw his energy you saw how he
was running and you saw how he got in
the car and you'll never forget that
maybe you'll pick up the phone and go as
a red Cadillac or whatever the [__] it
is but if there's certain things that
you see in your life that you'll never
forget like you just never forget you go
that was [__] weird like
I don't know I had a lot like when Don
Henley picked me up hitchhiking you know
what I'm saying like what are the
chances what are the chances of [__]
John Denver picking you up hitchhiking
on Fourth of July to go up Snowmass you
know you look at those things and you go
oh no forget that the rest of my [__]
life you know
but she just looked at me a certain way
she goes listen I just she was plain and
simple I just want you to grow up and be
a man
I'll never forget that she had tears in
her eyes
and she turned around you know she went
downstairs because breakfast is ready
whatever the [__]
but I'll never forget how upset she was
that night and how upset she was
when she told me that she wanted me to
grow up to be a man and it was a simple
statement like I just wanted to grow up
to be a man not to have a fancy car not
to have any of this [__]
but just to understand what goes with
the territory of slinging dick and doing
whatever the [__] you want you still
gotta answer you know it didn't make
sense to me until I found her on the
floor a week later
because that was probably the 31st of
October as she died on November 7th but
it was after midnight so they claimed at
the eighth so you just when I found them
on the floor and I called the ambulance
that's when that speech rang in my head
and it rings in my head
constantly you know and uh it's not like
some guy yelling in your head you know
saying like this is something that when
something happens whether
you know you do I still remember you
know getting to an airport at five in
the morning going what the [__]
what the [__] what am I doing with my
life it's 4 45 in the [__] morning
and I'm in a [__] airport to go to
some town and I'm and I would go but I
made a commitment
you know there's been a plenty of times
when I'm at an airport and I'm like I'm
not standing on that [__] line you
know especially when you fly Southwest
and in La it would be outside the
[__] door
and I'm like I'm not [__] uh flying
on that [__] plane you know but
that's all what it comes with the
territory of being a man is saying that
you're going to do something
and stick them to the [__] sentence
you know and uh I'll never forget that
and now we're going into that area you
know and it's 43 years and
I've spoken to my therapist about it
speaking about therapists and now for a
word for my [__] sponsor
all right you bad [__] this
podcast is sponsored by better help
sometimes you can fix that on a problem
so long that you don't take the time to
find the right solution but when you
learn how to find your own Solutions
there's no better feeling sometimes a
therapist can help you become a better
Problem Solver making it easier to
accomplish your goals like they did for
me I love better help I love Dana and I
love their therapy and how they worked
on me for you guys that don't know
better help is an online therapy that
offers video
phone and chat therapy sessions you can
choose and not to see anyone on camera
but it's more affordable than in person
therapy okay prices are high out there
you won't get a therapist at least with
better help you'll have a therapist but
in 48 hours when you want to be a better
Problem Solver and you want your life to
run smooth therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com
Diaz again
betterhelp.com Diaz and I'm going to get
you 10 off of your first month that's
betterhelp.com Diaz and now back to the
Joint Jack
all right mouses were back from better
help in fact tomorrow's my last therapy
session but out after a year and a half
we've worked it we've talked it over and
uh that's it went to the end and it was
great and I really enjoyed it and if I
could recommendating anybody
I would do it all over again it's been a
[__] great journey with those people
I never had a therapist before granted
it wasn't a lady on a couch with a
[__] watch you got to go in there
nobody's doing that no more because of
covert you got to pay [__] 400 an
hour
and uh better help did do the [__]
job for me yeah you look at my [__]
look at the Joint three years ago and
look at the Joint now beside the [__]
Band-Aid I'm doing a lot goddamn better
you know what I'm saying I had abandoned
in my soul before now I got a band that
in my [__] face so
but uh yeah that was a great time for me
not a great time for me but it was a
great learning experience
and it's so weird how by talking to a
therapist I spoke about this every once
in a while my mother and because and the
other reason why I want to talk to the
therapist about my mother is because and
I don't mind disguise I do not mind this
at all in fact it's it's the most
flattering thing you could do for me if
you really want to hit home with me I
love when people reach out and go Joey
I'm gonna bind my mother's in the ICU or
something and I need a prayer or
whatever or Joey my mother died last
night or my grandmother died I get
five of those a month and I write you
the best note I think I can't but I also
lie to you a little bit and I tell you
that
just live to the dream that they wanted
for you and
not the pain but that that [__] that
[__] side that thorn in your side
goes away in time anybody who's lost a
parent knows that uh you know it just
it's mind-boggling it [__]
mind-boggling I don't know how people
survive it and I don't know how the [__]
I survived it on Honest Engine when
people tell me now that they lost their
parents or somebody passed away like
their mom or grandma and they were tight
with them it rips me the [__] apart but
I enjoy talking to them
for just you know five [__] minutes I
know exactly what to say for five
minutes because I was there I was there
and I remember the people who came into
that wake and spoke to me and how they
spoke to me some people were [__]
jerk offs but I had such [__] great
people that came in and said this is
where you're gonna this is what you're
gonna go through this is what's gonna
happen this is what you're gonna feel if
you ever feel this contact us but anyway
that was a long [__] time ago I just
want to let you guys know that the time
is inevitable for all of us and time
will lose a parent and you'll think of
my Uncle Joey and go [__] this was I
think the magnitude and how it hit me at
16. not only that it's not like getting
a call that your mom got hit by a truck
while she was walking on [__] a
Boulevard I found her I found I saw the
purple arm
I saw the purple around her shoulder and
uh that'll stay with me for [__] ever
and I again
it was the drugs you know let's face it
nobody just does a pound of coke a week
because they like it you had to shut
down the pain somewhere and the acid all
those years on the acid which are now
coming back to fruition you could tell
I'm [__] getting [__] by the day
but all that [__] it made me past that
pain
and there was no therapy back then guys
it wasn't like you know you called
somebody on your [__] internet screen
you know it was I didn't even know I
didn't even know what therapy was you
know nobody ever said you know people
said if you want to talk what does that
talk about she's gone I can't bring a
[__] back so
it was a tough thing it's gonna be 42
[__] years next week 43 [__] years
and uh it's something but if I have to
credit being here it's the guys like
Rego it's the guys like Glenn Fernie and
Roger
and there's a lot of other people but
those acknowledgments when I wrote those
technology like it made me call like
five kids and go hey I need a picture of
your family
and they're like why and I'm like
because I have to put them in the book
I have to honor them for what they did
for me at that time I never knew the
magnitude of it until I was writing that
their thanks to all these different
[__] families so
it's uh it's been a great [__]
Journey
and I think the writing the book was
[__] therapeutic as [__]
so it's been a [__] great journey
guys and uh
sometimes I think for me the therapy was
good the face-to-face therapy but
matching my personality to writing it up
for some people you know they don't want
to talk about this [__] writing it out
and what you were really really feeling
at the time really [__] helps uh I
can't tell you how much it does so
I don't know what the [__] we're talking
about the Monday I'm supposed to bring a
little joy to you [__] we got a
great week coming up I gotta talk to you
about a new movie I got let's break it
down [__] Tuesday morning
I get up at five in the morning I'm
coughing I'm drooling I'm [__]
myself and I'm not having the best
morning in the [__] world I drink
some coffee I get dressed you know I
jump in the shower I come downstairs
it's got to be maybe 10 30. it was one
of those mornings where I got up at five
and then fell back to sleep about seven
you're gonna love this [__]
so I'm not in that [__] office two
minutes and my phone's ringing I didn't
even know who called yet as I [__]
made the loop the phone starts ringing
it's my agent and they go Joey
you know the girl answered Joey hi you
have a call okay and then she's like hi
how you doing the agent says listen you
didn't get the partner dinero movie but
you know they might come back at you
with something later on the week or
whatever they just want to keep an open
door they want to contact you and thank
you and I said that's great and and guys
listen there was no uh there was two
seconds of sadness you know and I know
the game so I didn't hang up the phone
with my my agent goes they're going to
call you in like five or ten minutes
they wanted me to call you first to let
you know they were calling they're gonna
call from a New York number just be
ready
I don't put the [__] phone down and
the phone rings but it's not a New York
number it's my friend Nick valonga we've
had him on the podcast and he [__]
wrote the green book he wrote an Academy
Award for the green book
and I'm like what's up Nick how you
doing because I called Nick a few weeks
ago for a different friend of mine
that's got a script and he wants Nick to
help him with it Nick said he would help
him with it so he wanted me to just get
past it along to him so
he calls back I tell him what I want and
he goes well the reason why I'm calling
you is not because of that
I want to know if you're available in
November to do a movie and I'm like
yeah
yeah I'm available I have nothing going
on he goes do you have any stand-up
dates
that'll [__] uh [__] this up and I
got November 3rd which is a Wednesday
night
and he goes that's no problem we're
going to start shooting on the third and
you don't think your first day is like
the fifth or something I go perfect
and I got the night before Thanksgiving
and he goes well that's no problem
either because we're taking that week
off for the holiday I go perfect let's
do it he goes all right I'll call you by
the end of the day now guys
when somebody says they'll call you by
the end of the day that means they got
to go talk to somebody
and they have talked to two or three
people their producers the executive
producers
the people who are putting the money
down and they gotta tell them this is
what their thoughts and in that process
if me Mike and Leah producing this movie
Lee's Got Somebody but Mike has somebody
Mike has an end with an agent that said
they get a better person than me
whatever which is guys it's fun
I didn't hear from him Tuesday he told
me to call him by the end of the day
Tuesday so when he didn't call
I scrapped it guys I didn't hear from
Law and Order I was on for okay
Wednesday I did a bunch of [__] we did a
podcast I called Esther to come do the
podcast because I found out Monday
Esther had released her product she sent
me a picture and I'm like Esther how are
you gonna release it without doing the
podcast or let's get in the ball style
let me help you out with this so I
called Lester okay and a lot of yous
looked at me when she came on and go
what is Joey thinking about to happen
that's the guy she has a great product
she's smart and I just wanted to help
her get it out there and some of you
enjoyed it you know I couldn't say much
I didn't want to [__] be an [__]
and start talking about [__] shots and
all that stuff so I tried to keep it as
professional as I could and I enjoyed
myself I had a great day with them
uh uh Thursday you know I haven't been
feeling well blah blah blah so
Friday I'm doing something I'm running
errands I gotta go get something at
ShopRite I got to stop at CVS
and when I get in the car in front of
the house I'm not even at the [__]
corner and my my text goes off and it's
my agent one of my agents from my line
he goes listen
get by the phone we're about to call you
with an offer
author
I go well maybe the dinero movie has a
little role for me [__] it I'm not doing
anything
so I kept driving and I pulled into a
parking lot by El Nido and [__] uh
they call and then it's like this is
Mike this is Jay this is Steve we're all
on the same call you know what I'm
saying and the one guy goes all right
who's going to tell him and he comes on
he goes hey my kid uh great great guys
you know
Mikey I just want to tell you we
received an offer for you for the movie
uh
you know That's Amore
I think he's a friend he is Nick
falalonga
and he goes it shoots in Jersey
starts November whatever
um
let me tell you who the cast is if
you're interested like oh I'm definitely
interested Nick's a great guy you know
the guy wrote an Academy Award why
wouldn't I want to work with the [__]
guy right so
I go yeah and he goes let me tell you
who's in the movies like John Travolta
you're playing John Travolta's friend he
goes you and Andrew nice clay and
[__] Catherine heigelberg and [__]
uh whatever her [__] name is uh Dan
Aykroyd
are you [__] kidding me Christopher
Walken are you [__] kidding me uh
Chazz palm and Terry Drea Mateo Talia
Shia D.B Sweeney I mean there's a bunch
of [__] people in this movie I'm like
[__] yeah
[__] yeah shoots in November Northern
New Jersey in my old territory [__]
Hoboken what I'm in [__] so I
hit Nick up Nick thank you very much for
the opportunity I love you [__]
and he goes let me send you a script
so next week
well this week is going to be a rough
week Tuesday I'm doing this [__] uh
physical and then Wednesday
I might have to go with a wardrobe
whatever the [__] to take a covert test
who the [__] knows that they're not
gonna tell me [__] till uh this
afternoon later on this afternoon or
early tomorrow when I'm in when I'm
[__] recovering from the blood test
that's when I'll get the call well
you're working these dates and these are
the hours and I don't really give a [__]
guys I got nothing going on I got those
two shows I'm excited for and this movie
so it's gonna work out [__] perfectly
and I sat there for a minute
I'm like Jesus [__] Christ I just
auditioned for four movies
and didn't get dick right nothing nobody
called nobody right nobody wanted to
talk to Uncle Joey
and uh
this guy just calls me up
and offers me a movie I go I wish people
knew this I wish people knew that
when you're in this business
yes
talent's got a lot to do with a lot of
things I'm not saying I'm talented I'm a
lucky [__] Okay Talent has a lot
of things
it has to do with your good karma and
what you're putting out I gotta be
honest with you guys when I got that
call and I hung up that phone with the
first thing I thought about was
Esther
Esther that I went out of my way like I
do I try to do this every [__] day
and you could ask Mike you could ask Lee
I try to do something nice I try to make
your day every day
even if it cost me money I'll make your
day because I know
that's a better chance of me having a
good [__] day
that's the first person I thought of was
little Esther putting her on the podcast
you know with no I don't want any money
from her you know I'm [__] 60. she's
37 where am I going I mean you know or
if she's 37 she may be 35 or something
right I mean where am I going I did this
from my heart I did this because I
missed her I hadn't seen her you know we
text from time to time during the week
from from the weed store and stuff I
hadn't seen it I go I'd love for you to
come to Jersey do the podcast hang out
and she was like I'll be there [__]
with bells on
and guys like I always tell you the
universe will always take care of you
you know even though people aren't
watching the universe is always watching
everybody's always my phone's getting
tapped you know everybody's always got
everybody thinks they're [__]
important okay nobody's watching [__]
nobody's watching if you talk to [__]
Alexa yeah they're gonna be listening
but nobody's watching you [__]
nobody's got your phone typed you know
the CIA doesn't even know who the [__]
you are the FBI I don't know who you are
stop trying to be cool but remember one
thing
the universe is always [__] watching
they gotta [__] you don't even see it
when you wake up go next time you shave
or brush your teeth look at the mirror
you got a little stick behind your head
with a [__] camera to see where your
daily activities are and they [__]
log it so when you kick a cat when
there's nobody around or you [__]
throw a rock and an old man and [__] the
universe is rocking you know the
universe is watching when I was a kid
and I used to torture Mr Martini why I
think I always had [__] bruised knees
and [__] up elbows and stitches all
over the [__] place because I was
torturing an old man throwing rocks at
him and [__] you know Pebbles and
invading his [__] privacy now he the
universe is always watching guys and
when you do good things unprovoked like
just something from your heart you know
Rudy star has always taught me so much
in this life
in all our podcasts I always took
something from Rudy because he's such a
[__] brilliant dude you know he's 70
[__] 3 72 70.
he tours with these kids just to give
them love and he says it it's it's a
labor of love
and for years he spoke about Labor love
like a labor of love I'm like what's
this [__] long head Cuban dude
talking about and one day it finally hit
you know when you see people like Joe
Rogan
and you say to yourself well he's a dick
he's dying let me tell you something he
had a plan all along if Joe makes a
hundred dollars he gives you 50.
he gives you 50. he wants you to eat he
wants you to dress well he wants you to
smell well Joe always open up the door
for you and he'll he's opened up the
door for so many [__] Comics he's the
[__] Johnny Carson his generation and
I was one of those Comics so when he
gets 100 million dollars you want me to
tell you why he gets 100 million dollars
not because he's the smartest guy in the
world not because he's the funniest guy
in the world because he puts good [__]
out there not to you [__] Joe
you're never going to see Joe with a
picture of him with a check I donated a
hundred thousand dollars to The Blind
Association we don't do that in our
church we don't do that in our church
I'd rather help somebody out here in
front of me somebody who [__]
struggles with me every [__] day then
worried to tell you guys I'm worried
about the ozone layer no you're not
you're just saying that [__] because you
want to have friends that's how you make
friends
my house
doing little things it's not even about
guys it's not even about money you ever
been treated with money has anybody ever
treated you with money where all they
have to offer you is money
they don't want to be your friend they
don't want to talk to you about nothing
they don't want to [__] go to a movie
it's all about money with you that's how
they take care of it you know I was
reading something the other day about a
girl who's going against her father
because you never paid a child support
or whatever you know
who the [__] knows
if you do something from the kindness of
your heart
it goes a [__] long way man and
that's my Monday [__] message for you
[__] [__] on the joint Jack we
got a great football game tonight if you
want to contact DraftKings do what you
want to do I had a great weekend with
him I didn't do uh
I didn't watch the UFC
the Yankees you can't even watch them
they can't even hit the ball I think you
know they got to stand in front of the
they're trying to get hit by the pitch
and I told my wife yeah they just put
that leg out and tried to get hit by the
pitch now to get on base that was a that
was a very disappointing [__] show
and and that's it and that's that
[__] I don't know what my
schedule is this week but we will try to
give you another podcast Tip Top Magoo
and one I realized what the schedule is
I'll let you [__] know so you
know what to expect from Uncle Joey stay
black have a great week and now for a
word for my [__] sponsor Jack
all right I want to thank you guys in a
beautiful Monday morning for listening
to my [__] today but before you go
to podcast is sponsored by better help
listen you got stuff going on in your
world you got stuff going on in your
life and you want to find the solution
that's where better help comes in
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions you can choose or to not see
anyone or to see somebody and it's much
more affordable than in person therapy
I've been with them for about a year and
listen when I got here to better help I
was a [__] mess and now I'm Tip Top
Magoo swinging dick with three ants
who's better than you nobody better help
you want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there okay visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz Diaz to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com Diaz the 10 off
your first month that's betterhealth.com
Diaz the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen the post office is
going to be there's gonna be more
[__] people in the post office next
month than in the Immigration Center in
Mexico they're going to be everywhere
and steps.com has everything you need to
make your life easier it's a virtual 24
7 post office no lines no traffic no
hassle how easy is stamps.com me and my
wife have been with stamps.com for about
10 years now tremendous stamps.com gives
you access to post office and UPS
shipping Services right from your
computer say up to 30 off USPS rates and
80 86 percent off ups and all you need
is a regular computer and a printer and
you'll be tip tops Magoo no special
supplies or equipment be up and running
in minutes and get ready for the chaos
you could print official postage for any
letter package anywhere get ahead of the
holiday chaos this year get started with
stamps.com today sign up for promo code
Joey for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter the code Joey it's that simple
the joint is also brought to you by CBD
lion listen when it comes to CBD CBD
line is the best how do I know because
it's been in my world for about four or
five years I don't switch governments
[__] go to CBD line right now and
look at the third party lab results read
read about CBD CBO CBN and get your
world Back in Balance on the way out
pressing code Joey joint or church and
get 20 percent off your first order I
want to thank CBD Lyons betterhelp.com
and stamps.com but most importantly you
[__] savages for supporting The Joint
stay black have a good day and I'll see
you Thursday love you
[Music]
[__]
foreign